let me ask you something I'm Jonathan
Parker you know the park my middle and I
eat where is that what is your middle
name okay I don't know why I said I love
that means the weird like Jonathan Edgar
Park FBI name no my I was more Argentina
yeah he was and you were smuggled ROM
like smuggle me and my little sister to
through the Mexican border stop stop
from Argentina to Mexico and then to LA
then Mexico it must have been much
easier if you were Asian because you can
like jump on trees right and rooftops
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna be using you your mom to
babies you or you were one of the babies
yeah was your dad there no no no no so
my dad I don't know the full story but
my dad first came to LA on his own like
to establish like his thing you know
what I mean like to set up shop or
something yeah and then my dad sent back
money from my mom to get snuggy and
through the Coyotes the guys yeah yeah
yeah come into the Mexican border me my
little sister who was one and I was
three he wasn't nervous I mean he
probably just act like it was a
dangerous thing I don't know how like
when my dad was thinking you know yeah
that it was like a safe thing or you
know but yeah so my mom explains cuz I
was too young you know so my mom kind of
explained to me that whole journey and
she said it was mad scary like wow they
end up in Argentina to begin with so my
mom's side like when she was like 15 my
her parents moved to Argentina to like
just there was a huge immigration of
like Asian people at her South America
and in my dad in his early twenties went
alone just for like business mm-hmm they
met that's X at us pretty much riots
pretty mother they still together
nah they split up soon as they got to
America they're like oh we're allowed to
divorce okay cool Oh
I mean I mean not like super early but
when I was like 12
oh we could break here or no huh you'll
break your heart oh yeah I mean honestly
like just my childhood I don't remember
like a happy moment between them too
like they thought like every all the
time in the household it was like you
know just didn't have a good you know
relationship I was always wondered like
how they ended up together yeah I mean
and then when they split that's when
everything kind of got better for
everybody all right yeah you see live
with your mom I was like back and forth
oh yeah
hyung come on he'll come on huh
Charlie yeah yeah I'm decent I'm not
great either
you know kind of uncomfortable still
when I use it yeah I felt a little
comfortable right there yeah oh you did
that tells me that let me say something
let me see where you're at I wanna see
where you're at
yeah yo yo what's up that was yeah go to
taco man what'd I say
say you dick is small and that's real
just right oh there's another what facts
facts well chat what's that man you say
so it's just like this is like a slang
for like facts you know when you really
agree with something you know okay okay
let's it lets you say something and I
want to see if I can say it say
something
yo Wingstop got the best hot wings yo
facts that's if you were like really a
sight like you like someone said
something like you don't really agree
with you but you know there's a way you
say that one yeah you gotta say it like
you're putting a period or how about I
say something right okay man that guy's
dick was delicious it was delicious
be in the scene again Sound speed Rollie
action yeah man so I was sucking that
guy's dick and his [ __ ] tasted like
[ __ ] vanilla milkshakes yo that was
good that one take no bean milkshakes
[Music]